Billy when did you know you would be
like a professional musician I feel like
with you it was like even when you were
like a little like 5 years old you were
writing songs I feel like you knew
almost immediately yeah I I mean I
started I made my first record when I
was five I know and I didn't know what I
was really doing and then I really
wanted to learn how to play guitar so I
started that when I was eight and then
um yeah I think you know as soon as I
especially I say around Junior High is
like when you know around 12 13 14 years
old I was like yeah this is I you know
I'm not going to be big enough to play
sports or anything like that so uh you
know I think music was the thing for me
5-year-old Billy Joe Armstrong look for
love is the name of the song 3 4 5 6 7
look for love look for love look for
love look for love look for Love For
Love
you needed M based on this
seems and somebody
strong with a smile and a
song look for love look for love it's
not bad I mean for 5 years old yeah you
should have seen his backstage Rider
when he was five man yeah right L M&M
chocolate milk you know Tinker
Toys it's so great I love that you you
took singing lessons but you took them
in secret because you were afraid the
kids would in the neighborhood would
beat you up yeah but yet what a
brilliant thing did did they help you
yeah absolutely Mrs faton she they I
mean she she just showed me how to um
carry a tune and kind of know how to use
my voice and use like my diaphragm or
whatever yeah and then uh she yeah I
mean she was great and uh yeah and then
but she it was a m small music school in
in penol California called Fiat music
and so I would go and sing like in
convalescent hospitals and veterans
hospitals and I would uh you know I had
gigs all the time and I'd wear like
Tuxedos and uh really yeah yeah yeah it
was uh it was pretty fun you would go in
as a solo guy and play like an old age
home yeah yeah and I would it's like
sometimes I would sing like uh songs
like satin doll or Chicago and I would I
would like it'd be kind of funny to see
like a like a nine-year-old being like a
lounge singer or something like
that